cavar trincheras para protegerse y hacer
frente a la invasión rusa
en kiev estos hombres y mujeres se
alistaron como voluntarios están listos
para luchar y
creo que ganaremos aunque será difícil y
lo romperemos para que sus hijos y
nietos lo recuerden siempre bajo la
amenaza de un ataque se extiende sobre
la capital el asalto parece inminente
mientras tropas y vehículos blindados
rusos se estacionan a apenas 20
kilómetros miles de civiles se han
movilizado para defender su ciudad en
este punto de entrada a kiev los
habitantes del distrito controlan el
ingreso y la salida de vehículos
nuestra principal tarea es asegurar que
el equipo de nuestros militares y
servicios especiales pasen normalmente
sin problemas la gente se siente
positiva todos creen en la victoria
todos están armados y se han incorporado
a la unidad de defensa territorial de
ucrania hay antiguos abogados
comerciantes conductores personas que no
tenían experiencia militar antes de la
invasión rusa de ucrania
cuál es mi motivación quién más va a
serlo porque los ciudadanos desde otro
país se lo harían por mí alguien va a
ser nuestro pues nadie puede hacerlo por
el pueblo y los ciudadanos de ucrania
y
el ejército ruso se enfrentará a una
población dispuesta a defender kiev a
toda costa el alcalde de la capital
advirtió que el conflicto se cobraría
muchas vidas pero también prometió que
los ucranianos nunca se rendirán